[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
magazine qui vous raconte les aventures
économique du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines aujourd'hui nous
sommes à la ferme de romainville ici
mélanie et jonas de la lampe travail au
quotidien ils ont repris la ferme en
2019 jonas s'occupe de la production
céréalière mélanie a ouvert son magasin
en 2020 un magasin qui vend des produits
de ferme locale aux alentours deux
entrepreneurs agricoles qui ont connu le
salariat en entreprise nous allons vous
raconter leur histoire mais avant cela
regardez le programme du sky échos c'est
le 43e numéro la dernière étape du bic
tour c'est le 20 septembre prochain au
vélodrome nationale un événement dédié à
l'entrepreneuriat est organisé par bpi
france en collaboration avec saint
quentin en yvelines ils ont connu le
salariat mais aujourd'hui ils sont
entrepreneurs mélanie et jonas de la
lande dirige la ferme de romainville et
le magasin de produits locaux la
start-up l'accord a développé un concept
de sûreté mobile et transportable de
contrôle d'accès du public sur des
grands événements basée à montigny le
bretonneux elle va entrer dans une phase
d'industrialisation
[Musique]
durant ce mois de septembre nous faisons
un gros focus sur l'entrepreneuriat en
lien avec un événement qui se tiendra le
20 septembre prochain au vélodrome
nationale un rendez vous organisé par
bpi france la banque publique
d'investissement en collaboration avec
saint quentin en yvelines et cet
événement c'est le big tour
[Musique]
c'est une grande journée dédiée à
l'entrepreneuriat au sens large avec
toutes ses composantes dans un esprit
festif et promotionnelles de tout ce que
nous pouvons faire ici à saint quentin
et en ile-de-france en faveur des
entreprises du territoire
les thématiques couvrant champ très
large
l'emploi l'innovation
l'environnement la création d'entreprise
[Musique]
et le programme du bic tour est très
dense entre des témoignages
d'entrepreneurs des conseils pour
entreprendre ou encore la découverte de
métiers la thématique de l'emploi
résonnera aussi au vélodrome national
avec le big job dating entre 13h30 et
18h30
on aura des temps forts autour
d'animations de conférences animées par
l'ensemble des entreprises des acteurs
économiques du bassin de saint quentin
en yvelines tombe bien souhaité se
mobiliser là sur des thématiques très
large l'innovation la création
d'entreprise l'emploi les métiers de
demain une émission très atypique qui
s'appelle vivent ta ville et qui nous
permettra de mettre en avant tout la
valeur de saint quentin en yvelines un
événement important également pour
montrer aussi la dimension de cette
journée qui quels une opération qu'on
opère plutôt en fin de journée sur
france 2030 avec un aspect industriel
aujourd'hui qui est important dans le
cadre de la relance économique
et la journée se conclura par un concert
du groupe skip the use pour plus
d'informations notamment pour participer
à cet événement rendez vous sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
[Musique]
la ferme de romainville c'est une
exploitation agricole mais depuis
septembre 2020 c'est aussi cette
épicerie le garde manger c'est une
épicerie spécialisée dans le circuit
court et la dirigeante est la fondatrice
de cette épicerie c'est mélanie de la
langue bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors est-ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer
un peu déjà le concept tout à fait alors
l'idée c'était déjà de diversifier
l'activité agricole de la ferme donc on
marie a appris à la l'exploitation
agricole en 2019 et moi je voulais
également du coup trouvé ma place au
sein de la ferme est validée c'était
d'ouvrir une épicerie en vente directe
pour valoriser notre production agricole
mais aussi pas que puisque nous on est
agriculteur céréalier donc on a une
petite partie de des produits du magasin
savoir de la farine de l'huile de colza
des lentilles nous ce qu'on voulait
c'était essentiellement proposer des
produits frais donc les fruits légumes
de la viande la crémerie la charcuterie
et ce en direct des producteurs c'est
vraiment un concept qui nous tenait à
coeur
puisque on a vécu plusieurs années en
province notamment à la rochelle et il y
avait plein de magasins de producteurs
d'ailleurs y en a un peu partout dans
les régions de france mais très peu en
ile de france pour ne pas dire zéro et
donc l'idée c'était vraiment de pouvoir
aussi proposé ce concept aux habitants à
côté de la ferme sur un magasin en
direct des producteurs et donc du
circuit court alors votre mari c'est
jonas de la langue qu'on le retrouvera
tout à l'heure justement il a repris
l'exploitation familiale en 2019
exactement et donc depuis il est
agriculteur céréalier je le disais vous
finalement enfin d'ailleurs tous les
deux vous étiez dans le salariat avant
et puis vous avez basculer dans
l'entrepreneuriat qu'est ce qui vous a
donné l'envié de vous lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat alors déjà il faut
savoir sur par depuis le début de
l'histoire on s'est rencontré dans une
école donc une école d'ingénieurs en
agriculture à angers et donc je pense
que déjà de par notre formation on a eu
les notions pour voilà se lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat plus tard
et après donc jeunesse lui en fait son
parcours s'était un peu tout vu c'est à
dire que c'était une vocation pour lui
de reprendre la ferme et donc de
s'installer en tant que l'exploitant
agricole et moi en fait c'est aussi une
histoire de famille puisque mes grands
parents étaient commerçants mon papa est
toujours commerçants et les cavistes et
vraiment eu aussi du coup une aide
familiale qui nous a incités à nous
installer très tôt et qui nous a
encouragé dans cette voie là en me
disant allez-y vraiment c'est une
aventure exceptionnelle est plutôt vous
ferez mieux ce sera pour une aventure
une aventure parce que c'est plein de
rebondissements est ce que on ne sait
jamais comment on va être lendemain on
connaît pas nos journées à l'avance
c'est vraiment des métiers ou en fait on
doit être tous les ballons voilà la
polyvalence c'est
vraiment
la clé du métier puisque on est à la
fois gérant d'entreprise donc
gestionnaire il ya une partie financière
administrative comptable enfin rh ça
prend tout en compte mais aussi
apprennent que c'est la forme il ya le
fond aussi donc voilà l'entreprise en
elle même un pouvoir gérer les stocks
les achats à la vente le commerce
marketing la communication et j'en passe
donc voilà c'est vraiment ça englobe
beaucoup de métiers différents donc ça
que je parle d' aventure parce qu'en
fait il faut tout réapprendre à main
avant de parler de votre quotidien
comment s'est faite la transition parce
que je le disais avant vous étiez dans
le salariat vous étiez dans une
entreprise de de l'agroalimentaire
comment vous avez vécu cette transition
ce changement ben justement où avant
peut-être que vous étiez sur déjà
plusieurs tâches mais là vous êtes
globalement à gérer tout ce une
entreprise finalement alors je pense que
pour nous c'était vraiment nécessaire
déjà de voir ce qui se faisait ailleurs
donc de démarrer dans le salariat dans
des entreprises un peu différente moi ma
part après l'école j'ai travaillé dans
des entreprises agroalimentaires alors
déjà à l'international je faisais de
l'import export du trading voilà sur le
marché après nationale et après j'ai
travaillé sur une échelle un peu plus
local auprès des restaurateurs en leur
vendant tous types de produits
agroalimentaires mais toujours voilà
dans cet univers de l'alimentation
c'était vraiment une très bonne
expérience pour moi puisque ça m'a formé
sur plein d'aspects différents du métier
de commercial ce que je faisais avant
mais du coup j'ai aussi
vu ce qui me manque à cette heure que
mon métier manquer de sens j'avais
besoin de choisir les produits que je
voulais vent de choisir ma clientèle
j'avais besoin de prendre les rênes un
peu aussi de mon avenir de ce que je
voulais faire de ma vie donc c'était
très formateur vraiment très
enrichissant pour en tout cas pour ma
part mon expérience ça m'a apporté aussi
pas mal de notions pour démarrer sur les
parties agro alimentaire puisque voilà
il ya beaucoup de choses à savoir mais
après c'est aussi je pense qui fait
qu'on a envie de se lancer à son propre
compte vous dites des mots forte quand
même prendre les rênes de votre vie
c'est ça l'entrepreneuriat si on
pourrait la définir avec complètement en
toute façon après on est on est un peu
le capitaine de notre bateau 1 c'est une
métaphore très simple mais c'est un peu
ça on choisit l'équipage et puis c'est
parti mon blog vers l' aventure comme je
disais tout à l'heure donc on essaye
quand même beau succès un horizon avec
des objectifs qu'on veut atteindre mais
mais c'est vraiment ça l'idée je pensais
c'est de choisir la direction où on veut
aller et comment on veut y aller le
bateau le garde-manger puisque cette
bêta porte ya combien de demandes dans
l'équipage alors on a cinq salariés
voilà on a 4 4 salariés temps plein et
un apprenti
[Musique]
et
puis
je suis jonas de la langue je suis
agriculteur à magny les hameaux sur la
ferme de romainville
on est sur une surface de 350 hectares
que l'on cultive donc blé orge colza
maïs ont fait également depuis deux ans
de la lentille et du tournesol pour la
première fois cette année en espérant
faire de l'huile de tournesol j'ai
repris la ferme familiale en 2019 donc
mon père arrivé à la retraite et m'a
demandé si je souhaitais toujours comme
depuis tout petit reprendre
l'exploitation jeudi a pas de problème
on est la cinquième génération de la
famille de la lande sur la ferme de
romainville avantage d'être son propre
patron passé quand on prend ces
décisions on est autonome on peut avoir
son emploi du temps donc c'est aussi
beaucoup de contraintes avec beaucoup de
stress des petites nuits comme qu'en ce
moment il fait très sec et on voit pas
trop comment on va s'en sortir au niveau
des cultures mais c'est aussi tout le
bonheur de pouvoir être fier de ce
qu'ont fait de ledevoir qu'à soi même
doubler par l'entrepreneuriat je voyais
plus sa com de com de la comptabilité en
fait c'est plus derrière le bureau et
puis d'avoir la gestion va dire un peu
financière mais en fait c'est une
perpétuelle remise en question se
demandait ok cette année il a fait c'est
qu'on n'a pas trop marché comment est ce
qu'on peut améliorer comment est-ce
qu'on peut toujours essayer d'aller de
l'avant et c'est de progresser pour
essayer de suivre l'évolution climatique
aussi qui nous impacte donc voilà
maintenant se lance sur les lentilles le
tournesol parce que c'est des cultures
qui sont plus du sud à voile a cessé
d'entreprendre et de d'aller de l'avant
pour anticiper sur tout
des entrepreneurs et on est très
polyvalent c'est vraiment ça qui me
marque le plus il faut être bon
mécanicien conducteur de tracteur faut
savoir avec un salarié gérer un petit
peu toute la partie rh faire de la
comptabilité aussi est très technique
parce qu'on utilise de plus en plus des
gps et des outils de cartographie
satellite pour travailler dans les
champs
[Musique]
créée en 2018 est basée à montigny le
bretonneux l'accord a développé un
concept de sûreté mobile et
transportable de contrôle d'accès du
public sur des grands événements
découverte du prototype du lapd ou avec
le président cofondateur et yann crouzat
je m'appelle yann crouzade j'ai 44 ans
je suis le co fondateur et président
depuis le mois de juin de la société
l'accord
[Musique]
nous développons des concepts de
contrôle d'accès mobile et transportable
pour le grand public et donc tout ce qui
touche aux événements culturels sportifs
mais aussi aux sites sensibles
[Musique]
je vais mais qui paie avec ce que l'on
peut avoir de façon très naturelle
dessus sur soi dans notre quotidien d'un
téléphone d'un portefeuille d'une clé
tout est réglé de façon à pouvoir faire
en sorte de fluidifier les flux
donc voila comme vous le voyez avec tout
ce que j'ai dans les poches téléphone
stylo clé badge la machine n'a pas n'a
pas sonné
[Musique]
maintenant l'idée c'est de se dire le
tient
je rajoute en un couteau et l'a du coup
je deviens dangereux et je vais le
mettre
au fond pas d'air dans la chaussette
dans la chaussette lors d'une d'un
contrôle de sac l'agent de sécurité ne
le verra absolument pas et lors d'une
palpation sauf si elle est poussée c'est
pareil c'est compliqué à venir faire une
palpation jusqu'à emballé cheville donc
on va voir
vous
on lave ou la vente à dionne à une
détection on peut aller voir peut-être
sur la table est ici où se situe la
détection
la machine a bien analysé la personne
mais aussi l'endroit exact où se situe
l'objet interdite
[Musique]
et
c'est maintenant avec une sacoche oui
j'ai déjà dû du matériel personnel là ma
sacoche ou des papiers encore quelques
petits
quelques petites tables de batterie
franchement
on va prendre un couteau un gros couteau
et puis je voulais gagner ici à travers
mes documents
[Musique]
j'ai une alarme qui vraisemblablement
m'indiquer un problème au niveau de ma
sacoche voilà c'est indiquer ici donc là
il va y avoir derrière un agent de
sécurité qui va venir lever le doute
[Musique]
on va faire une démonstration de
simulation avec de l'explosif stimula
explosif qui correspond à peu près à 1
kg 5 julien va s'équiper de façon à vous
démontrer
que la machine analyse la chose
différemment
qu'une détection couteau ou arme à feu
on voit bien que le code couleur a
changé on est sur du rouge et on voit
exactement la zone qui est qui va être
pour le coup plus que sensible et où
l'agent de sécurité va venir
immédiatement levée de doute
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi une émission que vous
pouvez revoir en replay sur notre site
internet ou sur l'application mobile à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]